hello everyone this is manis sanani
i am the director of product management
for
ai infrastructure on google cloud and we
are here to talk to you
and tell you a little bit more about our
ai infrastructure plans on gcp
so why google cloud or ai infrastructure
that is the motivation for today's talk
to get you all excited about ai
infrastructure
and picking gcp for that first and
foremost
accelerators for every use case
are offered on our platform ranging from
accelerators
for doing low cost inference to high
performance training ranging from
small machine learning workloads to
large deep learning models
to natural language processing as well
as large-scale hpc workloads
secondly we offer the best price perf
for your underlying workload on a wide
selection
of accelerators including our own
proprietary first-in-class cloud tpu
product line
as well as nvidia's top-class
cloud gpus and last but not the least we
also offer
our compute optimized instances that may
make sense for
you and your workloads from a price poor
standpoint for hpc workloads
third easily to get started and scale
that is the primary motivator for us to
make sure that this
product this product line reaches the
masses
is to make sure that we have invested in
the tools and the services
necessary for opening this
infrastructure up to a broad range of
users
today our focus has been on ml experts
that uses the
ai infrastructure but moving forward we
want to address a wide range of
audiences
that includes data scientists but also
application developers
let me give you a little bit of a brief
overview into
why this matters why accelerators are
needed for ai
and why you'd want more tools in your
toolbox
so let's take a step back and kind of
look at what it means for us to be in
the ai boom
moore's law is ending um process of
transistor accounts no longer double
every year and a half
and that is the primary motivation that
tells us
why accelerators are important
exponential computing demand for ai from
this chart clearly shows that there has
been a 300
000 increase in compute when
customers have gone from alexnet to
alphago
as reference models the amount of
petaflops that are needed for
aiml breakthroughs roughly double every
three and a half
months and we at google would know this
really well
google has a number of products today
that use deep learning uh to power
these capabilities behind the scenes
whether you have used gmail
and have used autocomplete in gmail or
you've watched youtube
and have recommendations that youtube
provides based on videos you have seen
or you get recommendation based on apps
that you have downloaded from the app
store
those are all use cases of deep learning
applied at google at scale
this slide quickly shows you a view of
how
much demand there has been among
developers
and directories containing brain models
that are used to power several of these
google apps and businesses for us
taking that best practice and moving
that
and making that available to our
customer base
to our google cloud customer base is
really the motivation behind
the cloud ai platform that you have
heard on
several other sessions as part of this
series so let me just
double click and provide you with some
key areas where
this infrastructure powers capabilities
and services
across multiple industries whether you
are
a retailer and you have to offer
personalized recommendations
or doing demand forecasting or doing
visual search
or you're a financial services firm and
you want to focus on fraud and risk
analytics
or you're a media and entertainment firm
and you want to use
natural language processing or content
classification
all these capabilities pretty much every
box that you see on the slide
as a core capability across these
multiple verticals
can be powered or are powered by the
underlying infrastructure
that powers those workloads
ai is basically the electricity of the
future
and the way we look at this is the ai
infrastructure is the plumbing
that basically helps you make sure that
that electricity
passes through various businesses that
your organization is responsible for
so that being said um ai
for every level of expertise we are in
the business to make sure that we are
addressing
a variety of users using our platform
whether it is business users using
capabilities such as contact center ai
or document
understanding ai or it is data
scientists
using and building uh tooling and
platform tooling
using our ai platform development
environment or
it is going back to the plumbing blocks
of accelerators that i mentioned before
so we have ai for every level of
expertise
for every type of user on our platform
to summarize the two key personas
that we would like to engage with um
from an expertise standpoint on the
accelerators platform
is the ml expert and the researcher
persona
that uses these products typically we
however
are investing in tooling as i mentioned
earlier to expand that footprint to go
beyond
the ml expert and the data scientist and
open this
platform and plumbing available to a
wide variety of developers
using the tooling that i mentioned
earlier which is the ai platform
development environment
on top of that we have the automl custom
models
and on top of that we have the apis
which have basically pre-trained models
so effectively we have ai for every
level of expertise
double clicking on that we have cloud
tpus cloud gpus and cpus
as our core accelerators that i
referenced earlier today
moving on let's now do a double click on
the hardware accelerators that are
offered on the gcp platform
first and foremost cloud tpus
google tpu is a piece of hardware that
lives in a google warehouse it's managed
by cloud and it deeply integrates with
tensorflow it is designed from the
ground up
to accelerate machine learning and deep
learning workloads
for both training and inference models
cloud tpus enable businesses
and researchers to train and run
more powerful and more accurate models
than ever before
at faster speed and scale cloud tpus can
reduce
the cost of machine learning work and
speed up the time to market for new ai
applications
because instead of investing in
significant on-prem infrastructure
you can access this level of
supercomputing power
available to you on demand through gcp
access the most powerful supercomputer
available
and pay for only what you use
it is built for ai on google cloud it
offers you fast iterative development
via a variety of tooling that i'll go
over in a bit and it offers
proven google qualified reference models
that are optimized for performance
accuracy and quality lastly i want to
share
that cloud tpus have been designed from
the ground up
to accelerate machine learning and deep
learning workloads
they enable you to train and run more
powerful and accurate models
ever before at faster speed and scale
and can reduce the cost
of machine learning and deep learning
models and
increase the speed by which those models
take to train
thus making your business more effective
and more
agile so what's new in cloud tpus
since since we last talked about this
cloud tpu pods
rnga since uh since december
of this year both v2 and v3 pods are now
publicly available
we have a pretty broad growing ecosystem
that is supporting the platform today we
have pytorch 1.5 in beta
and we have tensorflow 1.15 as well as
tensorflow 2.2 today available
for cloud tpus in addition to that as i
mentioned
our goal is to make this platform and
make ai infrastructure available to
users across the board we have also
invested heavily
in integrating cloud tpus with our
google kubernetes engine with gke
alongside with deep learning vms on
cloud ai platform that i'll talk about a
little later today
and we offer several supported models
out of the box
with this platform now that i've covered
extensively what the google cloud
tpu portfolio covers let me give you a
quick overview on the google cloud gpu
portfolio
google cloud offers a wide range of
nvidia gpus and we work very closely
with nvidia as our fantastic partner
so whether you need a cost effective
inference
or scale up or scale out training we
have the right gpu for you
for your underlying workloads we offer a
suite of six gpus as this
slide shows and i'm super excited to
announce that we
just uh launched our a2 vm family on gce
with nvidia's brand new ampere gpu this
gpu
offers up to 16 uh we offer up to 16
gpus on this which is
uh super exciting and quite a
differentiator for our cloud
moving back if you look at the previous
releases
we were also forced to market and bring
t4s to our cloud
t4s has the same tensor cores
as the v100 it's a fantastic option
for scale out training if the v100
compute is
beyond your needs besides our a100 v100
and t4
gpu products we also have p100
k80 and p4s that have been on our cloud
for a couple of years
now that you heard all about our
infrastructure how do you build
train and deploy using our ai
infrastructure
in your environment first start ml
workflows
on-prem meet the customer where they are
by deploying and helping customers
easily
lift and shift their workloads from
on-prem to cloud
this is where our kubeflow notebooks
comes in and our q4 pipes line come in
one such example is qfo pipelines which
is a no lock hybrid solution
for production ai workflows let you go
from on-prem to cloud
for your bursty deep learning training
workloads
qflow notebooks along with q4 pipelines
and ai platform notebooks
really bring together all the tooling
you need
to get your models operationalized the
key point here is that it is the same
code that runs on premise
that runs on kubeflow with almost no
code changes
what this does is it gives you our
customers the ability
to build wherever you want and then move
that code
to production without retooling or
recoding for infrastructure dependencies
thereby taking advantage of the
underlying plumbing
offered through cloud tpus or cloud gpus
as i mentioned earlier
moving on let's quickly talk about how
we would help you optimize for perf or
cost
um as you're looking at your deployment
options
so i'll quickly mention that cloud tpu
scale really well
these start with 16
tpus on a chip and scale up 210 24 gpus
and we offer this product today in a
variety of sizes
that is available on our website you can
go and read more about it
but giving you all a quick overview we
offer this product today
ranging from our tpu donut which is our
smallest piece of product
it's not shown on this image to our pods
which start
at a 1 8 of a pod and go up all to an
entire pod
in terms of scaling what you can see
from this slide is
as you increase the number of chips you
can
see very quickly the
scale out that we get we get a 33x
speed increase by actually
increasing the number of chips that we
are paralyzing
the deep learning model on and this is
where tpus
really really shine they give you really
the best price perf at scale
for your deep learning workloads that
basically require a matrix
multiplication super computer in the
background
that is what cloud tpus are
moving on from tpu scalability gpus also
we offer a variety of scales for our
gpus as i mentioned earlier
our a100 gpu launch with the new a2vm
will allow you to scale up your memory
needs
from 85 gb ranging all the way up to
1.36
uh terabytes to t flops of 19.5
and in terms of gpu configuration the
a2vm
is particularly differentiated by
offering 16 gpus
that are interconnected to each other
and scaling up to
96 cpus with a system memory of up to
three terabytes
um not going to get into the details for
the other uh
other skus but the main message i want
to land here is that
we offer you the flexibility you need
to run your underlying deep learning
workloads
all your high performance computing
workloads on our gpu families giving you
flexibility to spend on what you want to
train on
versus renting hardware in an on-prem
environment
24 7 365. so you really just pay for
what you use
that being said we also offer
preemptable gpus so if you
are you know not in the need of
on-demand reserved capacity 24 7
you could use our preemptable vms with
gpus allowing you to run your batch
workloads on
pools of gce or gke capacity and thus
only pay a fraction of the normal
on-demand price
so this is taking our capacity making
our capacity
available to you and offering our access
capacity as savings
these preemptable gpus are now
discounted up to 70 percent
um and up to 80 on vcpus and memory
when you're using preemptable vms versus
on-demand vms
and what i have up here is a quick quote
from a professor from kavlon i was
assistant professor at stanford
university preemptable gpus have been
instrumental
in enabling their research to process
large video collections at scale
using the scanner open source platform
the key message here
we are here to save you money we are
here to make sure that your tco
is the optimized for your underlying
workload
that being said let's now move into the
third piece of the topic which is
how do you easily start and scale
so how do i take advantage of
accelerators in gcp
there are three ways you take advantage
of accelerators and gcp first and
foremost the ai platform
secondly the kubernetes engine and
thirdly
the compute engine let me tell you a
little bit more about each of these
um via the ai platform we have a variety
of tooling that i mentioned earlier
the one that i wanted to particularly
touch upon and make sure
that we drill in hard is using field for
pipelines i went over that earlier today
so we just quickly skipped that
via gke using containers thus enabling
gpus and tpus as a service and by doing
so
you the customer we are removing you the
customer from the burden
of managing that hardware or that vm for
your underlying workload so you get to
focus
on your ai modeling and the
infrastructure responsibilities
are taken care of by that integration
give your containers access to gpus via
kubernetes api
and then take advantage of auto scaling
and looking at that
gpu utilization and scale up and down
those workloads
as your demand changes you could apply
this similarly
to tpus as well i was just using gpus as
an example
and last but not the least via compute
engine
compute engine offers custom vm shapes
tooling and workflow support to scale
from gpus under your desk
to having super computing scale
available on demand
via preemptable as well as cumulative
as well as cards and reservations
custom vm shapes are offered for better
performance and cost our
virtual servers are available in many
configurations including pre-defined
sizes
or options to create custom machine
types optimized for your specific needs
so what is included quick overview
ai platform has a number of tooling like
i mentioned earlier today
we've got data labeling built in
algorithms there's a training
platform there's a deep learning images
notebooks
predictions not going to get time to go
into all of the specifics
but the one thing that i do want to
double click on today is one of our most
popular services
on the ai platform which is deep
learning vm images that will help you
get going on this infrastructure
immediately so
deep learning vm images easier and
faster machine learning and ai on gce
deep learning vms let you get started
easily on our ai infra within minutes
by offering you fast prototyping to
prototype your ml projects quickly with
pre-configured vms
for deep learning they offer out of the
box
cpu gpu or tpu support so you can choose
whatever infrastructure makes sense for
you for your underlying model
and get single click access to that
infrastructure
to accelerate your model training jobs
you could switch from one
to the other you could go from a gpu to
a tpu and back and forth
very easily and last but not the least
gives you the flexibility to choose
different ml frameworks
like tensorflow pi torch or cycalon out
of the box
the one thing i want to call out here
with the deep learning vm image
is ar performance optimized for google
cloud so we do build these images
and tune the libraries and configure
them so that you as a customer get the
optimal performance
on our infrastructure without worrying
about building all of that
end-to-end yourself
moving on here's a quick quote that
talks about
offering higher accuracy at lower cost
which is what we aspire to offer to
every customer
snapchats monetization algorithms have
had
the single biggest impact to their
advertisers and shareholders
the nvidia t4 powered gpus
that snapchat uses for inference on gcp
today
enables them to increase their
advertising efficacy
while at the same time lowering their
costs
when compared to a cpu-only
implementation
we are also able to offer this
capability to
snapchat through a variety of locations
we offer t4s in a variety of locations
around
our globe today so having global
availability
of this gpu powered instance for
inference
for snapchat has been a huge win for our
customer and
we would like to extend that to several
of you
that being said hopefully you found this
session useful
and productive for any q a
and follow-up please reach out to us via
cloud.google.com
contact and with that being said on
behalf of google cloud
i want to thank you for watching our
talk on ai infrastructure
and i look forward to really hearing
from you and engaging with you
on a one-on-one on on a personal basis
thank you very much